check out this story from the daily mail
this is i'm telling you man
when they write about this era with
donald trump and russiagate
this story is going to be one of the
keynote like the key
you know portions of it highlighted in
the history books and as much as there's
probably a lot of people you can't see
it when you're in it
i'm telling you about these riots right
now too oh for sure like the 60s
all over they're going to be like the
riots of 2020. they are going to write
about the day glenn greenwald
resigned and issued a scathing
resignation uh
resignation letter saying that the
people at his company are suppressing
information
they refuse to allow him to write about
a major scandal involving the
presidential candidate's son
and they wouldn't even let him publish
in a third party so he's forced to
resign
now we have we have the barry weiss
resignation at the new york times
saying it's like it's it's a woke
brigade you can't go like everyone's
it's ridiculous it's not even news
anymore you had matt taibbi leave
rolling stone
now he's publishing his own news on his
own substitute and charging a couple
bucks
glenn greenwald the founder of the
intercept this like
i remember when the nsa leaks dropped
and glenn greenwald and lore poitras we
had all this information
we learned about all this crazy stuff
the nsa was doing edward snowden flees
to russia where's he going where is he
going what's going on it's crazy
glenn greenwald goes to brazil launches
the intercept with pierre omidyar
there's a lot of criticism because
omidyar's
i think is the ebay guy and so now we're
going to have this new beacon of hope in
journalism
today glenn greenwald forced to resign
from his own company
and he said he started it to prevent
exactly what it's become media
the news media in this country has
become a propaganda arm of the
democratic party
period so whose money got involved that
prevented him from being able to publish
this story
because it seems to me the biggest
problem here is he didn't stay
independent he's
clearly some financer who was able to
push him around i don't think that's i
think it's that
and it's and and i i don't know to what
extent glenn greenwald manages this
company but if he's the founder
i mean it's his fault he let a wolf into
the henna house yeah did he
send the company or is it a fox fox it's
a fox i mean
either would be bad either would be bad
and actually fox is unfair
it was actually a bunch of uh foxes and
they were wearing gigantic
fake chicken suits and they were like
walking in and he's like looks good to
me
that's what they said a fox and chicken
suit clothing yes yes
and then eventually he's sitting in this
chicken coop wondering why there's no
eggs coming out
and he's like well you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna go you know get a chicken here
and they were like no
you can't have chickens make eggs here
and he's like i literally created this
and then all of a sudden the chicken
suits come off it was foxes the whole
time the whole time yeah but we're
in that moment right before the chicken
suits come off he just wonders why he
couldn't get any eggs so
no he was on it what a poetic putting it
we're getting it yeah this is the moment
that's how they're going to strive and
hit subscribe in history books the
moment before the chicks
came off i hope that what we discussed
left the intercept there will be like a
historical record of some sort and it'll
be like
green glenn greenwald's resignation was
was heralded
you know and and touted as as this
historic moment by
podcaster and commentator journalist tim
poole who said
it was like a bunch of foxes wearing
chicken suits filling that chicken suits
off all at the same time liverpool's
famous
chicken suit yeah and then one of the
great quotes of broadcasters and all
yeah
it's gonna be there's gonna be some like
some little kids they're reading their
history tablets or whatever and they're
gonna be like
and what did tim poole say on that
fateful night when news media changed
tim poole said that all of the foxes
were wearing chicken suits
and then all one at a time took off
their chicken suits
that's right and there's gonna be like
reenactments the foxes were in chicken
suits
and the chicken suits came off and then
it's gonna like get turned into some
folk story where
tim cool stumbled upon chicken suit
wearing foxes in a literal
penthouse and fought them all in a
thousand years
there's going to be like like 200 years
it'll be like abe lincoln or george
washington's cherry tree no but like in
a thousand years it'll be the epic of
the chicken suit and it'll be a story
about like
dom uh like the name's wrong and they're
like
the the chorkin sats and they're like i
wonder what a chorkinson was you know
what i mean like
and a forks what are these things we
don't know i wonder what they really
meant
anyway now that we're very very silly my
question about the intercept
i don't know if any if you can draw it
up literally if it's too much is if it's
a public company if they took it no
no it's not so it was uh it was a
private he never
went public and that he still gave stock
to too many people so
no no it's not a i don't i don't lose 51
of the equity or something no no no it
was private it was privately funded
by pr i don't know how he set up the
corporate structure
but i'll tell you this interesting if
you start a company even if you're the
founder
and you have a hundred employees then
one day it turns out they're all
in a cult yep what are you gonna do
you're gonna fire everybody well you can
if you're the owner if you have more
than 71
i don't know to what extent like i don't
know how glenn greenwald organized this
company
but it seems like he put himself in a
position where he was just a personality
and he signed over the company of the
money yeah maybe that omitter was
running and i'll tell you what
that's i'll tell you what it's kind of
funny because it falls
it falls in line with kind of what we
were predicting when he did it
you you want to launch a news company
and you get someone like pierre omidyar
this ultra wealthy dude don't be
surprised when he eventually walks in
and puts a boot down over all of your
work and then you're forced to resign
seems inevitable the uh the
editor-in-chief betsy reid
said that he was throwing a tantrum that
his claims were preposterous
yeah how do we feel about that they're
lying yeah i've talked about this quite
a bit
that glenn greenwald will say something
reasonable like
these stories about russia are
ridiculous and there's no evidence 100
and then a day later someone at the
intercept writes donald trump
is a crooked you know russian asset or i
don't think they've said that at the
intercept
but they write like the most ridiculous
unknown fascist president donald trump
does blah blah blah
i love that journalism technique where
they do the unnecessary qualifier
yes yes 100 so instead of saying
something like
uh you know they could say animator and
comedian you know sheamus uh
uh coughlin am i pronouncing it right
yeah you got it right
i know what they'll do is they'll go
they'll say sheamus uh
coughlin comma a far-right extremist
agitator
it's like or provocateur that's their
favorite one for like anyone who does
any kind of comedy that they don't like
is considered a provocative
hitler provocateur too no they just call
everyone a provocateur
it's funny when they they call like ben
shapiro provocateur yeah it's like he's
like dude
going out of my way to provoke people
he's not even close okay i gotta say it
i've been very turned off by greenwald's
association with the intercept lately
anyway
yeah i'm not a massive fan of of
greenwald but i don't think he's lying
about this
no he's like it seems like a really
strange thing for him to make up
especially right before the election
because he is left-leaning he's not a
trump supporter at all
no he's critical of trump he very much
does not like trump or the right wing at
all
so and matt taibbi not that long ago did
a podcast where they were ragging on
trump that i thought was
i i look i think you're entitled to your
opinions not entitled to your own facts
and i think they had a lot of opinions
that were based off of incorrect facts
and so i'm watching and i'm like that's
the media and that was matt taibi i
can't remember exactly what it was but
it was like wasn't the biggest deal in
the world
for someone like you know matt to come
out and be like we can clearly see this
is bunk fake news
we're talking about with russia i'm like
this dude's legit like he's absolutely
good he's willing
what he's willing to look at the facts
and say this is you know what is and
what isn't
glenn greenwald does the same thing
that's a rarity
in journalism today and and you know
what a part of you know this
gives me a bit of hope these these
high-profile journalists leaving and
doing their own thing
at the same time it's also kind of scary
when you realize the institutions are
now zombified
so are we is that it is news media done
because if they can lie about you and
get you excised and banned from
everywhere
then it's only a matter of time before
they just get anyone who's in their way
banned because they're
what do you mean they get anyone the
zombified news outlet so like the
intercept could now start writing a
bunch of stuff saying
matt tybee known white supremacist and
then eventually put false quotes against
him and then
petition you to get him banned and all
we've got is like the legal system is
our
is our defense mechanism it's a private
platform you can't do anything about it
can you really not if someone makes
false claims against you dude the
the if i called you a nazi you could not
sue me
nazi is an opinion it is it is a social
it's an incorrect statement of my
political affiliation nope i'm
affiliated independent
colloquial usage of the word nazi means
50 million different things
yeah that's also true and this is why i
think one of their favorite words is
alt-right
as well i mean like calling someone
alt-right is not as extreme as calling
them a nazi so you don't sound
non-credible saying it but it's a
complicated yeah it's just an opinion
there's really no definition
there is it means ethno-nationalist
technically but they use the associated
the associated press has guidelines on
what alt-right means they just don't
care
yeah and then what are you gonna do when
when seven thousand outlets
write an article calling you an
announcer you're gonna go sue seven
thousand people good luck
yeah you're not gonna have the money to
do it and they're getting a screw-off
you just gotta get one big player
to lie about you like um like uh
nick sandman and then you're set then
that's a really obvious lie
i was so happy when that happened you
know because there are so many little
lies that they get away with every day
and then they're like you know what
let's just go out of our way and try to
destroy this kid's lives and then
life and then blatantly lie about it
remember when that happened
there was the black hebrew israelites
just screaming
really like horrible like things that if
any uh conservative group or white group
was out there screaming the media would
be saying oh this is homophobic this is
racist this is bigoted
uh in every possible way but then the
media described them as um
young african-american men preaching
about the bible and oppression like
after this you ever see the movie the
animal with uh with uh
rob schneider yes no i haven't seen it
but i know you're talking i'm going to
spoil it for you guys though
wait no that's him spoiler alert he's
too old of a movie you're not allowed
i know honestly here's the movie the
movie is about you know rob schneider i
guess i haven't seen it since it
was a long time ago he gets hit by a car
or something and then he's got like
he's dead and then this mad scientist
gives him a bunch of animal parts
so he's part animal i guess he has like
a hairy ass i guess
he can jump really high and then he has
just you know he acts like a superhero
movie yeah because rob schneider loved
doing these movies where he turned into
things
but anyway right there so when we became
a woman would you what that was hot
chick yeah
he became old no no no no no woman
became him oh when we became him well
hold on all right this is important this
is important so in the movie
he's apparently like running around
killing animals or doing something wrong
and then finally an angry mob
comes for him and he's like oh no what
do i do
well his friend who's black is like i'm
going to defend him
and so finally when the mob's like
surrounded him and ready to kill him
he goes it was actually me and then all
of a sudden everyone's like
uh and then norm mcdonald mcdonald goes
i'm not going to be a part of an angry
mob that's going after a black guy
and they all leave that's funny yeah
yeah i appreciate that yeah so
like yeah anyway i forgot why i brought
that story up that reminds me of um
that was next coming yeah the knicks are
coming today and how it's just good to
see the meeting at their time
they ignore the black hebrew israelites
yeah there we go and there's some kids
standing there and they're like let's
destroy his life
and then also literally again this was
part of the nature of the story but i'm
surprised more people haven't pointed
out the fact that they literally just
told everyone where he went to school
like they made the country hate him like
covington catholic school by the way
it's like okay they call him the
covington kid the covington catholic
school kid
and then they have the nerve to go out
there and complain about how trump's
comments make them unsafe
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you